do you think that people like he was
saying have
certain data to
to essentially make things better but
it wouldn't benefit them so they don't
bring it out
do you see it you can't unsee it
once you see it you can't i always
thought that but i didn't want it to be
true
well it's because like
like the minimum wage law it's so it's
so easy
like that you can be
i think you don't even need to be an
economist to understand that if you jack
the price up of something people less
people are gonna do it yeah so a lot you
know who hurts a lot from minimum wage
laws teenagers
really yeah because if you say um
we're only hiring people like let's say
they jacked it up to 30 an hour who are
the first people that are going to go
the least skills yeah teenagers
okay and low skilled people that are
trying to move up but they can't get
those jobs
okay that does make sense yeah and like
that's like to me that's so why why do
when they march the streets and they act
like they're
they're
fighting for the little guy they're
saying oh we're doing this for poor
people but that's not what happens my
parents run a business yeah if you jack
up the prices they either go to other
countries and hire people
or
or they just don't they figure out how
to hire less people or get it you see
the mcdonald's here the kiosks
that too just get robots to do because
you don't have to pay robots and it's
the same people that say oh i'm doing
such a good job i'm helping out poor
people but they're not doing [ __ ]
they're just making it better for
themselves essentially
man
that's that's interesting
one funny thing that i wanted to say
that i noticed about him because he was
like because the um the interviewer had
given his accolades and his backgrounds
and then he was like i'll make one
correction and he went through it to
like whole life story and i'm like
that's one thing that's one thing about
old black people they're gonna give you
every single detail about their life
it's like you could give like the big
points but they're gonna say i walked
here five minutes and i turned left went
right then i walked five minutes that
way i spun around and i'll give you
every single little detail i love it i
love it
you'd have to have a request go up the
chain of command to the secretary of
labor he would then confer with the
secretary of agriculture it would come
down the chain of command and
the department of agriculture to whoever
has those numbers and so on i said good
well they say a journey of a thousand
miles begins with a single step so i
will now submit my request to the
secretary of labor which i did and i am
still patiently awaiting this reply
and the institutional fear of the number
was what that
oh the us department of labor
administers the minimum wage law
and i and the
money and the careers of perhaps a third
or some other significant percentage of
the member of the labor department's
resources come from administering the
minimum wage law
one of the real farces of all this is
that the law itself section 4-d i still
remember requires the labor department
to study the employment effects of
minimum wages
and those studies are absolutely a farce
in fact some years after i left i did an
article saying why those those uh
studies were a force and when i came
back later on to the labor department to
do some research one of the older
librarians who remembered me turned to
the younger librarian and she said this
is the man who wrote that article that
has everybody up in arms
so you became you began to be dissuaded
about of marxism and of government uh
government in general because the the
the government uh is not out there at
the personification of the national
interest right they have their own
interests and the labor departments was
clearly an interest in
keeping the minimum wage because that's
that's their jobs and careers all right
and power in your which brings us if i
may to one of my favorite books your
2000 book this is a beat up old copy
this book conflict of vision yes which
you published in 2007 and you lay out
i'm sorry 1987. i beg your pardon
reprinted in 2007.
well beat up as this book is it turns
out this is the reprint sorry
1987
and you lay out two
competing ways of looking at economics
and politics really two competing ways
of looking at life that go back at least
200 years
the constrained vision
and the unconstrained vision
the constrained vision i'm quoting from
a conflict of visions sees the evils of
the world as deriving
from the limited and unhappy choices
available given the inherent moral and
intellectual limitations
of human beings close quote
so the constrained vision under itself
understands itself as constrained
by the limitations of reality itself yes
is that yeah that's correct yes okay
in other words they cannot proceed as so
many do that good things happen
automatically but bad things are
somebody's fault
got it
for that if someone has a constrained
vision do you think that they can
change their vision
i don't know if that's something that he
talks about is how you can go from like
a constrained vision to
seeing things
non-constrained
yeah i mean some people switch like
people
because
i think no guys i'm not
i could be butchering this but from my
understanding it's like
it's kind of like when you hear people
talking about how everything's the
world's fault okay so that's like
basically a constrained vision is saying
like the world is the cause of my
problems
okay so it's kind of like not taking
like
accountability yeah so it's like me
saying oh i'm a girl
i can't like all these bad things happen
to me because i'm a girl okay and this
this this i think guys correct me in the
comments if i'm wrong but that's i'm
pretty sure all right
that's interesting because
it
it's interesting because
there's people that live their life like
that like oh i can't do this this and
this because
i am
whoever i am
but
you shouldn't put yourself into
a box and be like i can't do this
because i was like no you can it's just
going to be harder there's going to be
restraints because
of whatever situation you're in if
you're
if you're going into more so a male
dominated company or a male dominated
area and you're a woman is going to be
harder and vice versa and if you
look different if you're different
ethnicity and this and third and you
haven't nobody's been in that sector of
whatever it is it's going to be harder
because either you're the first to do or
you're in a bracket where not a lot of
people have done it but just to be like
i can't do it
because i'm this it's like you're not
even trying it's just you're you're
already giving up before you even give
yourself a chance well and you know what
i've noticed the people that do break
barriers and those sort of things they
never really bring it up
because they don't look at themselves
like like through that lens and it's
interesting because an example i thought
of is when we did that show and we're
talking about consumer debt
you remember when we we did that live
show
and and they were like oh the reason
women have bad credit is because we just
want to look like better it's society
all this stuff but instead of just
saying no we spend too much and make
poor buying choices you're upset yes
like that's that's from the world view
versus like an individualistic view okay
gotcha that does make sense it's like
you're
you're pointing
the blame somewhere else instead of kind
of taking responsibility for your
actions
hmm okay